in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast you know a lot
of people have been asking me to get
like artists outside of what I do why am
I here yeah I don't do what you [ __ ]
do a man let me show you what I draw let
me show you what I paint I want to see
it she looks like death we got a couple
of special guests and one extra special
guest now expecting right so we have
Tommy Lynn and balloon ski what's up
yeah how did you guys get to meet each
other I we met through our mutual
friends there's a collective called
bloody gums they're a Skid Row LA art
collective in downtown LA and a Skid Row
yeah we call it look they they they're
in Skid Row keo skin Rokia yeah we're
kind of from the grindcore balloon ski
he is known for making really cool art
balloon installations and I don't we
just five you know he was the fellow
kind of degenerate drinker yeah we
started drinking whiskey right off the
bad night yeah that's what kicked off
first time I met him he had a bottle of
jam oh I was like no because they go are
you Korean yeah
doing some art for a establishment or a
festival called powwow and they do it
all over the world and there's one in
Korea and it was in Seoul this year
that's amazing
it was really amazing blew my mind I'm
gonna go back like right now see this is
this is like this is something like
somebody who doesn't do what you guys do
it's hard for me to wrap my head around
it right in terms of not so much as the
business aspect but how do you how did
you guys start developing your own style
right only because I asked us because in
specifically when it comes to art
whether it's what you guys do in this
type of realm or not it's hard to really
create your individual style and not
have it look like somebody else's I mean
people get influenced by other artists
right yeah yeah but there's gonna be a
certain part in your career or you know
with your art that it'll have to evolve
out of that and it becomes your own
thing so how did you guys get that to
that point I mean
it's just like it's just like you like
how did you develop your own style of
what you do you know I mean it's like
it's like [ __ ] that we grew up with I
said it alot our history too you know so
art history and trial and error you know
and then I like for me one of the
biggest moments was like oh I should I
should paint stuff that I would hang in
my own house like I never even thought
about that you know I mean cuz I used I
you know I like just like everybody I
love a lot of different things and it uh
it's just kind of just knowing the
history and practicing and doing all
this stuff you know yeah yeah I think
there was an alcohol I think like you
start from the moment you start with
your craft like whenever that is Tommy's
been drawing probably his whole life
I've been doing balloons for like eight
or nine years but I think the moment
that I took it because like you're
saying that that's your own perspective
in that the moment you take it and start
running with it and doing what you want
like he was saying painting for himself
doing what you think is cool I think
that's the break and for me personally
it's like balloon art is usually just
clowns and yeah birthday parties but I
started to make other different things
you know if you make like a gun with a
balloon or like a sword with a balloon
it's kind of this extra like I'm
thinking sharp or dangerous object made
out of something that can't hurt you
yeah I mean and and just kind of that
mindset to other things I started doing
street installations which don't last
for [ __ ] yeah but if you get to see it
while it's there it's dope yeah you know
and that's that's the moment and also
getting a picture for Instagram yeah
what I like about volutes key and my
stuff you know I did a lot of murals
yeah for people that don't know who I am
I paint I'm a painter I travel around a
lot and paint buildings and murals and
stuff but I like that form of art
because it's for everybody mm-hmm you
don't have to go to a fancy gallery you
don't have to like drink cheese and wine
or eat cheese and wine and she's like
yeah you can it'sit's for you can be
like a little kid to like a I'm gonna
know some art connoisseur to like some
bum in the street and you're like you
walking you're like OSHA what is this
and you know it's like it
some people react to it some people join
the same thing with his stuff he makes
balloons and a lot of times he puts it
into public somewhere and it just brings
joy or some people's like okay whatever
yeah so it's like kind of like for
everybody
I like that would you guys consider your
is it is what you guys do consider
street art is that what it is what's
like what would you title it I don't
know when I think a street art I think
I'm like a graffiti artist you know and
I used to do a little bit of that when I
was younger but uh that's a hard
question I'm just like art and it's art
right yes that's I mean I would say the
same thing or in general but it's a term
now street art is a term and we put our
stuff on the street so yeah let's just
embrace it like people can hate on that
name like a little McGrath dude like
street art swak like you're you're not
doing [ __ ] it's like man how many walls
do you have compared to some of the the
people that are talking [ __ ] about that
name street art you know I'm saying like
you're working we're working we're all
just trying to put our our brand out
quote-unquote you know so I don't see
any problem with the name although I see
a bunch of backlash with it and people
are just really like in what sense they
just hate on the term street art like
I'm not a street artist um oh is that
not considered real art well I mean
there's this whole oh man I just opened
a can of worms right I'm so curious like
Graff heads like dudes that just paint
tags and are really like core to the
streets they don't they've been doing it
their whole lives and now there's this
you know a bunch of like art school kids
don't know what to do with their degree
so they just start making art and put it
on the street and then they get a bunch
of like you know they get some push out
of it and you know they start to get
some money or get like brands noticing
them or you know getting paid to do
these things off of the stuff that they
did on the street but they just kind of
hadn't been doing it for that long they
just picked up on like really what the
graph dudes have been doing their whole
life and kind of adapted it to this new
like McDonald's version yeah so it's
kind of like they feel like oh you're
kind of stepping onto my turf without
giving me the due respect like you're
I'm like I'm selling you and you can try
to take over what I've been doing my
whole life I think so and that's just my
personal like
what I've seen about it I could be
totally wrong I don't know father
you know that's not just with him that
though there's everything like that
there's stuff like that with stand-up
comedy there's that same type of concept
with YouTube versus real Hollywood
actors they go oh your shit's not real
like I'm the one going into auditions
I'm doing this but then you're over here
getting booked for these roles just
because you have clout yeah so there's
that exist anywhere I feel like it the
the main core problem of that I honestly
if I were just to break it down to like
the molecular level of it or you know
jealousy it's jealousy yeah it's it's
hate through jealousy because they feel
like you are taking what I deserve yeah
you know well the one good thing about I
would say in general and art it's like
it's I mean it's competitive but it's
more like what kind of like cheerlead
for each other you know I mean like yes
now it's not like I'll [ __ ] this guy
like he got that role you know it's more
like this guy's turn into him [ __ ] he
said he's a cool dude like I wish him
the best you know so I think right I
agree with our friend your hope and with
the people that we [ __ ] with but most
of La is like rawr I could do you know
what I'm saying like there's a lot of
hate around here but that's why you know
that's what we found them with who we
fell in with because everybody maybe I
just surround myself with like good
people
I'm sure there's like the ugly side to
it I don't mean to go negative I'm just
saying no I agree with you because I
think more people are like that you know
and whatever group that you guys found
is it's really awesome because some
people feel that other people's success
takes away from their own yeah and my
thing is step your [ __ ] game up then
yeah you know step your [ __ ] game up
yeah and I had a conversation with a
friend of mine who was an actress and
she stopped talking to me for like a
whole [ __ ] year because of this
because every time I had a conversation
with her she would gripe about how
Viners and youtubers and instagramers oh
they're getting these huge acting roles
and I'm over here taking acting classes
doing this and they're taking what I
would I work for and I just told her I
was like why does it make you feel
better
to bring down somebody else yeah when
you're not being successful yeah you you
could have done that route yeah and then
you could have taken what they had but
you didn't so that's a personal choice
yeah like you don't I'm pretty sure
they're not sitting there and talking
[ __ ] about you yeah you know they're
just having fun doing what they're doing
you don't have to respect what they do
you don't have to like it but yeah
they're not doing anything that's out of
their realm that's taking something away
from you yeah all right life's too short
to hate you know yeah like live off of
hate like theirs I've seen some people
that might may or may have not copied my
[ __ ] too you know I'm always like ten
steps ahead of the game like I'm already
working whatever they they're copying
that was like that's old ship to me yeah
I mean so like I I don't I don't like I
don't get angry when I see that stuff
you know it's just like I already know
I'm on another place I'm in another area
you know I mean you have to because I
think once you reach a certain level
there's a lot of young people that are
going to look up after you guys they're
gonna be like I I want to be Tommy and
balloon ski you know and so they can't
help but images or no [ __ ] clue you
know drunk we should take a shot let's
let's do it has anybody ever drink on
your podcast
no because night old you like most
people they don't really I know that
they don't drink a lot of them do
[ __ ] drugs but say no to drugs all
right I bought a little Jameson please
sponsors yeah and me too
yeah brought to you by Jameson's a lot
of your product it has get something
they're really happy or to beat our
children I have to say that it really
really pisses me off when I see somebody
copy especially some [ __ ] that I'm
sister date the [ __ ] that I'm doing or
then the homies like that we said a
homie that they sniped his his whole
groove and put it on every Taco Bell
window on the west coast of this country
and like he just had to sit there and
what I mean you know we all kind of like
collectively agreed we're not really
gonna go to talk about that much anymore
like what else can you do
like there's no there's no like recourse
he's not the type to like copyright a
design and this kind of [ __ ] but I don't
know it's just that [ __ ] really pisses
me off but on the same time Burke's
always telling me like you got to just
give them that one
cuz you got plenty more you know yeah
yeah I don't care yeah cheers man
go BAE and David first of all thanks for
having me on your podcast man like I've
been a fan of your [ __ ] for a long time
and crazy stock oh thank you as well I
appreciate no I meant like I'm all about
putting on people that I respect and
number one if like Tommy is working with
you that means already off the bat even
ever I seen your [ __ ] I already know
it's [ __ ] dope like that's is that's
just how it is because I I appreciate
art and I feel like the generation
that's coming up right now yeah that
term of biting they they don't really
understand why it pisses people off they
don't understand that when you create
something right it took years and years
of experience learning and all this
other [ __ ] to get to this point to make
this one [ __ ] lot of blood sweat
tears pain cry and break it up with
girlfriends you look at my [ __ ] and then
you took it and then you profit it off
it I call it Xerox art it's a copy of a
copy of a copy yeah I mean it's never
gonna be the good as the first original
you know yeah and then uh and then
everybody's response to that is that if
I just let them live I hate that phrase
the [ __ ] most because I understand
it's applicable right if people are
doing their own thing and it's not
hurting anybody
yeah that's cool let them live stands
like that but when you still somebody's
life work let's not let them live
you just [ __ ] jacked everything from
them you know I mean even if it's small
and they'll get better than they'll work
on their own things there's there's
there's a reprecussions to that and
you're hurting other people in an
artistic way and also a career type of
way too and you don't really think about
that type of [ __ ] so people's response
to that is just oh well you got to get
[ __ ] influenced from somewhere
it's like yeah but not like that hey you
know it's different like I see like look
for example let's talk about music right
you got uh sure
uh sure dances and sings yeah huge
influences Michael Jackson but he's not
Michael Jackson you know that's that's
taking your influence and doing your own
thing and he becomes his own artist sure
you know Bruno Mars he has like this
whole New Jack Swing vibe or whatever he
thinks you know hello 90s yes or you
know anything and it's just like I
I find that such a hard pill to swallow
for me I don't I don't I don't like it I
want people to evolve and do their own
[ __ ] thing well this whole generation
is like nostalgia nostalgia dude like I
don't need to see a remix of [ __ ]
Care Bears or whatever the like I I need
some original stuff man like you know
like yeah I mean I like Star Wars and
kind of stuff but like Forster original
ideas yeah you know well you said you
started doing your your balloon art only
eight years ago that's relatively
[ __ ] recent yes not very long but
I've spent so much time doing it now
it's almost like a [ __ ] lifetime so
what were you doing prior to that they
may just want to switch over to doing
balloon art that's just [ __ ] unique
as hell playing punk rock and selling
weed yeah and I was moving to Miami from
the smaller town in Florida because my
chick had got this job with Estee Lauder
it was like this awesome job like yeah
this is yeah this is the one so I had to
figure out a way to make some quick cash
and I started making balloons and it's
really weird I don't know I was good at
it or whatever so I just ran with it and
smoked way more we've got all these
crazy ideas about making some stuff and
Basile was there so I started kind of
getting into the art world a little bit
then I moved to LA after my ex and I
broke up and I've just been pushing it
ever since so I don't really it seems
like a short time and when you say eight
years you know Tommy's been doing it for
50 times that long you know what I'm
saying
I am Confucius but yeah it's just a lot
of time and effort put into it you know
the that it's just I don't know passion
dedication I have this idea that it can
go everywhere balloons offer access like
I'm not painting a wall or I'm not
destroying something so I can attach
balloons to anything oh [ __ ] and so I
can get onto a ferris wheel and put all
kinds of crazy [ __ ] and it's not gonna
hurt
I think that we're all three of us are
similar in a sense where we have it I
don't know we we have a thing that that
makes us happy or whatever and we just
do it yeah yeah yeah yeah you know what
I mean there wasn't there wasn't like a
guideline for us to like oh yeah
how do I get here - we just [ __ ] was
ourselves and just did it's the follow
the path itself yeah this podcast is
brought to you by purple if you haven't
heard of purple you're probably not
getting a good night sleep my whole life
I have been searching for the best
mattress to caress my supple supple
Korean beautiful body and purple
mattress has been the only company only
to have matched my body suppleness is
that even a phrase I bet you it isn't
but purple is the spot for you son I'm
talking about this mattress is soft and
firm at the same time it's just right
it's just right just right for me just
right for my back and I know a lot of
you out there have been sleeping in pain
because you've been sleeping on those
springy box mattress type of stuff and
you have been fooled and misled your
whole life purple mattress actually was
developed by rocket scientist so it has
like rocket science technology in it so
you guys already know that it's going to
feel great probably be best sleep I've
ever had in my life ever since I've had
a purple mattress so my friends you're
going to love purple and right now my
listeners will get a free purple pillow
with the purchase of a mattress that's
in addition to the great free gifts
they're offering site-wide just takes
brain to eight four -
the only way to get this free pillow is
a text brain to 84-88 that's be our a I
n2 84-88 like I've never had I've almost
never had a job in my life you know I've
always like been self-employed shady you
know yeah yeah yeah you know I've worked
a bunch of restaurant jobs and she that
sucks I'd spit on [ __ ] food cuz
you want to spit on but you know washing
them dish that was my first job I go I
was washing dishes at this little BBQ
place on an island in Florida I got
fired the day because I tried to mix I
was cleaning the floor I tried to mix
bleach and ammonia together oh yeah
that's [ __ ] fun you're like I'm a
good that should extra clean what the
[ __ ] are you doing I'm like I don't know
maybe just make them a balloon I did if
I did I could got out of so much trouble
I was getting myself into
so he worked at so you did a lot of like
random gigs before like you really found
your your yeah just like job stuff yeah
once restaurants I did I worked at a
grocery store I worked as a computer
programmer that didn't last long I
started doing comm time later program
right yeah I had a computer circuit
board I tried I tried to learn a
language but that shit's like so I don't
know you're learning a language is the
[ __ ] so might my fiancee speaks four
languages fluently well so she speaks
Mandarin Korean English and Japanese and
she could read and write in all of them
whoa she's CIA she's some crazy would
think but she there's a lot of dumb [ __ ]
to say but congratulations by the way
thank you I love her to death but man I
mean she could she has more dumb stories
about me than her like I always am
amazed at her ability to absorb language
is so [ __ ] well it throws me off cuz
we went to Taiwan she was just talking
to everybody having a good
I never sent fluent honestly it got a
lot worse but she her I could speak
Korean but heard Taiwanese and Korean or
Japanese is better than how I could
speak Korean and my Koreans like not bad
so and she could read and write and
everything which is how the [ __ ] you
know what I mean you're supposed to read
it and write it first though right
before you can before you go into yeah
she took classes in courses if she lived
in Taiwan for I think about a year and a
half to two years and then she went
there just to learn the language in the
culture and then she lived in Japan for
a little bit and picked up Japanese over
there and she learned in the States as
well and so when we go back whenever I
go to Japan I'm like I'm just have her
in front of me all the time yeah yeah
and then some what if I go to Korea to
I'm not you know around Korea fine but
her Korean is way better than mine
yeah it is like a language ninja yeah
yeah she a teacher some two or she did
she ever taught a language I mean she
teaches like her co-workers Japanese all
the time they have like this Japanese
lesson thing during lunch that she
teaches everybody Japanese is [ __ ] yeah
she's she's amazing yeah man she's
[ __ ] psycho like you know it's
interesting to when somebody learns four
languages you realize that you're kind
of like a master of none so you you're
you're the rules kind of Bend and they
mix with different languages so
sometimes she'll say some [ __ ] in
English which kind of doesn't make sense
but I know they don't make sense in
another language so she goes my English
isn't that great I'm like listen your
English is perfectly fine you mess up
here and there but I'd rather no English
to a 90% capacity and then know the
other language is that another sixty
then just to know English a hundred
percent yeah [ __ ] that you know so I
always tell her that like the [ __ ] all
the you know you mix up a few words here
and there dude who cares like you're
English nobody would ever know that you
met your English isn't perfect it's just
that that bothers you a bit is she from
here sure she is from here so she went
to International School in Korea as well
so she went back and forth back and
forth yeah she's she was a wanderlust
she wanted to travel and when she really
does something she goes all in like
balls to the wall okay so she went to
Taiwan
and she just went to international
school there or other school and that
she learned the language and she lived
there for a couple of years she uh
biking around and so when she goes back
she has people that still remember when
she lived in like six seven years ago
yeah so we go back and it's it's like
her second home it's [ __ ] amazing I
think you got a good one man yeah she's
great man she was with me when I was
like two hundred and seventy eighty
pounds man and she thought I was cute
then I was like that's a good woman dude
yeah I was just like that's what you
know it's a keeper right hold on I gotta
hold on that when I had diarrhea every
day she was like that's just poop you
would you lost a bunch away recently or
like yeah I lost 60 pounds 60 pounds 60
pounds man what do you attribute that to
you know what it was for me yeah um I
just got tired of feeling sick you know
I think that once you know once you move
past 30 or you're in the 30 arrange I
didn't really you know I just thought I
was like I'm in my twenties I'm whatever
I'm good yeah my knee started to hurt I
started getting heartburn all the
[ __ ] time and to the point where
having heartburn was just normal
I'm like that's just everybody gets
heartburn right right so wakes up and
just throws a [ __ ] stomach acid every
day yeah you know I got heartburn every
day and that you know like I should you
not like diarrhea was like three or four
times a week
and I'm like that's just poop and then
you know skin skin was getting bad I
couldn't sleep very well
I started getting sleep apnea again and
then you know you you kind of you kind
of normalize all these bad things that
are happening to you and you just say oh
I'm you know I don't care about being
fat I'm happy right and I just do not
like I didn't know I was fat I say it
all the time on this podcast I'm pretty
sure people are tired of hearing it but
I just kind of lived in ignorance and
then one thing that you can't ignore is
health problems right having like acid
reflux constantly you know that's that's
from being fat yeah that's a report diet
choices to you you know not knowing what
you're eating yeah having like irregular
bowel movements like having a weird [ __ ]
yeah and then I just got sick of feeling
sick I was like this is weird you know I
mean like change your life a little bit
man like what you put in your body is
very
and now mind you I [ __ ] I do if
traveling food show I eat what I want to
eat for me to lose an extra 30 pounds
which would make me like really fit and
I'm not willing to do that I'm willing
I'm happy the way I am right now see the
pounds you look you look good I got like
this little here little package here
yeah I'm good
the two bucks I don't know if I'm
getting snow storm I need some reserves
you know so like I I got I just decided
to be a little healthier I started
walking everyday cuz that's like the
lowest impact thing that I could do
walking so like we live in downtown's
it's like it's just wrist walk and just
to get your mind off she just [ __ ]
walk something yeah yeah yeah I did that
and then in the first month I lost like
maybe one pound just from walking a mile
a day and then from that first month now
that I set that habit of knowing I could
walk every day seven days a week I
started changing my diet I did research
about what foods are good for you and
then I started changing my diet a bit
and the second month I lost like 13
pounds well and then after that I just
started slowly doing well now I'm at a
point if I want to lose the extra 30
pounds it's actually really hard I can't
just do the walking every day and then
eat what I want yeah and then yeah
that's what I get serious you gotta like
yeah no sugar like all that kind of
stuff but I always tell people to you
know be healthy to the point where you
can maintain that lifestyle if you like
you want a six-pack like [ __ ] you
know every day for the rest of the year
you best believe you're gonna eat the
shittiest food all the time in terms of
taste wise like do you want that life or
do you want to just be you know
physically healthy you lost a lot of
weight but you still got a little fluff
here and there you might have a little
bicep but then you still get to keep
your normal food a little bicep you know
my biceps like a centimeter bigger than
my forearms I'm happy you know so I I'm
learning to like balance like lifestyle
of food I want to still be able to eat
my late-night tacos and stuff I just
don't eat it [ __ ] three times a day
you know I want to eat burgers I don't
eat it every day yeah you know I should
once a day and so you what you want to
eat but less weigh less you and I don't
I don't eat myself to the point where I
feel like killing myself I would eat as
if I'm going to the electric chair the
next day like that's how I would eat
Yolo
like it's some song some crazy [ __ ] or
like you know you like do you ever take
like leftover so I'm like what's that
well I was leftover it bro yeah there is
nothing there my people would come out
to clean the table and it looks like
they just left everything on the plate
you [ __ ] fat [ __ ] what was it like
what was the draw to food was it the
taste were you addicted to taste because
I feel this like it myself personally
I'm a little overweight so yeah I've
thought about this like [ __ ] it like I'm
happy as [ __ ] yeah like it don't even
matter yeah like I've thought about the
molecular process of that yeah am i
addicted to taste does the taste take
away the voices or whatever let me tell
you something real quick the you I had
this thing worm I didn't really equate
it to this part of my life but I don't
like some some other [ __ ] substance
to control my life like yeah I'll if I
want to eat I should eat when I want to
eat like food should have beckoned me
and tell me to be its [ __ ] and that's
what food would does does to me right
that first week I was the crankiest
[ __ ] on earth like I live with
roommates at the time I call it man
grief yeah my roommate one time he came
down right he goes hey Bros like you
wanna you want to go for a while someone
go [ __ ] a walk with you you fat [ __ ] why
would you I might be a little irritated
and it's because we're addicted to high
carb and high fat foods these are highly
addictive foods there the scientific
studies to show that sugars in the high
carbohydrates are way more addictive
than nicotine and that's what it is we
go through these withdrawals if we don't
have our high fat high carb us and then
I started treating it more like oh I'm a
[ __ ] drug addict dude yeah I'm sure
what kind of [ __ ] is this like what is
what is the purpose of food yeah that's
for camaraderie and social stuff too but
it's in the ultimate goal is to nourish
your body yeah now I'm doing it in
excess yeah so it's like I got this car
and I'm filling it to eat plus another
gal yeah what were you eating the most
like what kind of food
tacos
shut up Peck yeah I would eat at this
joint call Avenue 26 tacos dollar tacos
rights in Highland Park the best yeah
Highland Park [ __ ] and uh
worse that want Lincoln Heights a leaky
Knights ok yes Avenue 26 tacos Leon
Avenue 26 right I blew that spot up
because I shouted them out so much and
then yeah I just ate there every [ __ ]
night and the reason why I don't go back
now is if there's a dollar and I can't
control myself like I have it's
impossible to eat one taco impossible
man it's like telling a looking crack
addict just to have a single Rock
who the [ __ ] eats one taco like that's
what I'm saying I don't trust you for
you once out goes I'm little and they
got those tiny tacos but they're dollar
each and you get six and you're [ __ ]
good right yeah but I like them so much
I'll get like seven or eight and then I
go home
heartburn and I'm going to kill myself
[Laughter]
blue leg yeah but I [ __ ] love me you
know people don't understand in Cali
Mexican food is where it's at like we
feel [ __ ] it lay food yeah tacos for
ya people people you know when I go to
these shows too sometimes out of state
and they're just like you let me take
you this bomb-ass mexican spotlight no I
don't want to go to your Mexican spot in
Missouri I don't think you understand I
live in [ __ ] la you tell me you're
gonna be some East LA taco spots bro
yeah I don't think so there any
cockroaches walking around around no
that's not good like all your [ __ ]
people that work at their Mexican
restaurant there are [ __ ] Mexican and
they don't speak Spanish you don't want
that [ __ ] dude then I want somebody's
abuela the [ __ ] had the recipe that
[ __ ] still
man cheers hey cheers guys right here
that's tight [ __ ] love it when white
people pick up other cultures man yeah
this guy will not stop talking about
Korea I can't first time in Korea oh my
god angels I don't blame you I [ __ ]
love Korea but you know some people got
issues with you know I mean I think
we're in this weird state where they're
like all I white people they're trying
to take our call my [ __ ] is this man as
long as like it's like anything if I was
like do respect them they will like it a
lot [ __ ] the prop you live in America
man like this is it's mixing of all
cultures dude like it's like first thing
you say she about like this type I like
that [ __ ] you know it's all about
somebody enjoying your culture right
this podcast is brought to you by
Skillshare you guys know when it comes
to lifelong learning I am a pro pro
advocate of lifelong learning
now if you've learned in a traditional
sense of learning in terms of school you
know that sometimes you want to learn on
your own pace and sometimes when you're
doing traditional education stuff you're
not learning the things that you want to
learn well Skillshare has your back baby
thousands and hundreds of thousands of
online courses that can help bolster and
help you on your journey to lifelong
learning if there's hobbies out there is
there something that you wanted to
pursue that you want to learn and you
don't even know where to start but you
know that there's a plethora of
information out there well guess what
that information it's on Skillshare me
specifically I've been using it for
photography I have definitely been
brushing up on my photography skills
specifically when it comes to lighting
because we all know that when it comes
to photography lighting is key no pun
intended
that's a photography joke in your face
but yeah Skillshare has helped me out a
lot and I'm always about learning at my
own pace because sometimes especially
because I've been to college I've done
all that stuff that I actually prefer
learning courses that caters to the way
that I want to learn at the time in the
pace that I want to
and that's where Skillshare has your
back baby boy and baby girl so join the
millions of students already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
just for my listeners get two months of
Skillshare for free
that's why Skillshare is offering genius
brain listeners two months of unlimited
access to thousands of classes for free
to sign up go to Skillshare comm slash
brain again go to Skillshare comm slash
brain to start your two months now that
Skillshare comm slash brain and you know
there was like issues where people
talked about you know like when white
people go to japan they're over here
wearing kimonos [ __ ] you don't
even know when you go to japan it's such
a tourist country if japanese people are
very welcoming they like it when you
were like their cultural stuff yeah
their biggest export is culture [ __ ]
even Hawaii it's the biggest export that
they have for sure you know and so
remember one that there was this article
where this girl was wearing Michael is
running this like Chinese style dress
right she was pretty as hell's for a
prom and this guy was like you don't get
to wear my culture blah blah blah blah
but people in China were like she looks
good what's your problem but it was one
Chinese American dude which by the way
on his Twitter they went through his
archives and he was dropping n bombs
like I'm talked about with a hard-r
throughout his whole thing it's like yo
where's your moral ground bro shut the
[ __ ] just wants to be upset about [ __ ]
all the time yeah I mean my [ __ ] is like
you wearing and you look good that's
fine it she's not it's not that she's
over here taping her [ __ ] eyes back
yeah you know like why oh I don't know I
I don't get the it's very like we grew
up with a lot of racism yeah but it's
very PC now I think it's like a little
too extreme of that yeah we like we we
need to be able to like laugh about each
other because yeah let's keep it real
weed we make fun of each other yeah when
the cameras are off you know yeah and I
gave like due respect there's a lot of
issues with that with food like I went
to this food festival and there was this
I forgot what her name was but you know
she's really sweet white lady and she
made this Dandan noodles and and and it
was like this peanut sesame sauce cold
or hot new [ __ ] bomb as hell right
she's got a hard off she's like yo like
I made this Dandan little just delicious
you know she's dressing it up for me and
in my mind I saw it I'm like [ __ ] knows
and then I ate it and it tasted good
it wasn't dan dan little so it was like
sesame noodles or some [ __ ] like sesame
oil noodles okay you know and I'm okay
with her trying to put her own spin on
it you know and I'm like I said I said
on the camera - I was like this is good
but she shouldn't call it dan dan
noodles because it's not dan dan noodles
at all Daniel noodles it's very it was a
it's just Asian tasting noodles yeah
it's really great she [ __ ] up on the
noodles she [ __ ] up on the sauce yeah
the the the garnishes were great you
know but I'm okay with saying that the
dish tasted good yeah it was still an
Asian dish yeah dan noodles that's all
yeah you ripped the sign down and run
away right I was like can I just wait
she [ __ ] up the peanut sauce yeah man
the peanut sauce peanut sauce that's my
favorite part of anything I think I feel
bad for people who have peanut allergies
because you will never taste great Asian
food we throw peanuts in everything dude
like Thai food than amis food [ __ ]
yeah mad [ __ ] that Taiwanese food
like it's it's crazy how people reacted
peanut allergies to because you know
like we have if we have like grass
allergies we might get hives yeah if a
[ __ ] gets peanut dust in their
eye their whole body shuts down oh [ __ ]
I always thought that that's like a new
thing like a peanut I never heard of
that shouldn't they know that she's
really I was a little kid who had a
peanut allergy on my church growing up
yeah and this fool had like a dust
dusting a pima air got on him and he
went into like anaphylactic shock
and everybody was freaking out but
that's when I knew I was a little [ __ ]
up in the head because I was dying
laughing oh you tell me this
[ __ ] died from a jiffy bottle
yeah but it's kind of crazy how people
react with those allergies I was like
there's moments when you grow up you're
like damn I'm not a normal person man
like why am i fighting this [ __ ] funny
like it eat anything I'm no you know out
on an airplane can't eat peanuts on the
airplane bro because if some other
people have peanut allergies they get
[ __ ] oh sure that's why they stopped
serving the [ __ ] oh that's why they
serve those shitty ass almonds now
[ __ ] almond because Southwest
Airlines used to give out honey honey
[ __ ] it you call that [ __ ] when you call
that [ __ ] the the honey crusted [ __ ]
peanuts and [ __ ] honey roasted peanuts
[Laughter]
yeah they stopped serving the Chanel's
my favorite stuff man
Oh like give like little toy airplanes
to the kids to some [ __ ] like on
airplanes hey back in the day man
smoking sections in there I wish no but
you know I'll be going in the bathroom
with that fate real quick I'm just like
not to create not to career though you
can't bring even a vape to Korea yo in
Korea if you get caught with weed you're
basically even at least like a weed
vapor it's the regular rate it will ne
me vape we have eight but they hate we
don't yeah it's mandatory three years
for locals that everybody kept saying
mm-hmm it's yeah I don't think they
realize how like number one I don't
really mesh well with weed because I
can't function that's why I don't really
do it we just smoke together right now
like I don't really mesh well with weed
very well because I get I get too in my
head and then I just sit there with my
mouth open and then it's five hour
passes right so I'm not really because I
was hoping number one I did it for it
because I was an insomniac I couldn't
sleep but then I was also hoping within
that realm I was gonna get some dope
thoughts nothing [ __ ] nothing dude
cuz I know you know people like dumb
like he would smoke and then he would
write [ __ ] and he would write some of
the dopest [ __ ] I've ever heard in my
life
yeah but I'm not a functioning weed
person and I'm not either dance not
everybody I'm like pass the Doritos
let's go watch a movie like you know
it cannot work on we'd like I'll sit
there with just my mouth open and a fly
would just land on my lip know what
Scully God you know saying it's the
worst being in a non-functional painter
non-functional weed smoking painter I
would like do like a couple strokes and
I just stare at it I would do the best
writing of my life dog like I know these
writers they smoke weed 24/7 and they
write some of the best content and I'm
just sitting there and I just have my
[ __ ] finger on an F key and I just
it's just the lines of the letter F
throughout the whole script I'm like
this is not it man is this maybe is this
a cultural thing I mean I'm not you know
trying to go you think dumbfounded smoke
so I'm not sure if he does I mean I
haven't kicked it with him in a minute
but I'm he's pretty open about smoking
this [ __ ] so I know he's most any
functions really well but maybe Korean
people just like to be angry and it
takes away from our culture assumption I
want to be angry all the time
so he doesn't make me angry anymore so
it's it's cuz y'all working 24 hours a
day dog work hard play hard break bread
you want to talk about [ __ ] play hard
man Korean people play hard war with the
W horn yeah like what do you call it
wait what's the korean term for
afterwards when you when you go drink
after you work not she make is it you
met or some [ __ ] like that
I'm not sure I can't remember basically
I don't work so if you work at a Korean
if you work at if you work at a Korean
company yeah afterwards like the bosses
or the upper management will go out to
drink and have smokes if you don't go
out to drink of smoke you might as well
just enter your career like you need to
go out and have that calm run and they
get smashed they'll sleep out on benches
they won't even go home they'll wake up
wash their face and go to work the next
day look I think that's dope yeah that's
crazy man yeah someone have to do office
work like that yeah when I get smashed
I'm done like I'm done for a couple days
you soft American South
I feel the same way like give me two
days I'll be fine the post maids you're
my best friend
what the [ __ ] that people do before post
mates when you were drunk you had to
find a friend that would get you stupid
[ __ ]
I don't remember cuz I was drunk yeah I
don't know man
yeah what the [ __ ] that we do before
that [ __ ] eat those crackers in the back
of the cupboard wiggle water make soup
in your mouth I got some bread I got a
little bit of Tang I don't know put some
together you know I like I don't really
handle alcohol as well as I used to like
I'm like a four or five shot one or no
right because I just don't do it as much
but I got smashed
I got [ __ ] smashed out of my mind and
not even on purpose yeah it was for this
for seven foods and we drank like seven
drinks back to back to back to back yeah
in a matter of ten minutes and you drink
like seven drinks like most drinks back
to back yeah ten minutes and there was a
glass of wine mixed all these [ __ ]
alcohols yeah and I don't remember what
the [ __ ] happened I remember I woke up
and there was this sandwich shop called
Primanti's and I had a half a sandwich
and it summer I don't know what happened
in between but that [ __ ] fell on the
floor so when I woke up I got out of bed
and I just went to the sandwich I was
like I need and I started gnawing on
that [ __ ] I [ __ ] threw it on the desk
the hotel room laid back I was like
please absorb that I'll go home I bet
that sandwich was it was the best funk
eating makes everything taste good
something about that late night leftover
the best Lee and I left over I ever had
was a Chicago deep-dish pizza personal
deep that I got from a place in Vegas
that I only ate like a half a piece
because I was so hung over it that at
that point yeah dinnertime I was
hungover and just woke up then I got
drunk that and I and went back and the
pizza was so perfectly like I don't know
it gelled up so yeah yeah cube of cheese
was a curiosity
yeah bread oh god that was the best shot
I ever had in the middle of the night
funny thing is like I know that well you
know what we drink right there's like
certain spots that we go to that we say
is the best [ __ ] on earth because we're
smash when we go there have you ever
wanted those spots those late-night
spots in the daytime I don't want to
talk about right [ __ ] with Taco Bell but
anymore they're so good
take another lady's oh that's all we had
in Florida was we're sorry to get a
fight you're a podcast a little bit all
right yeah we're just two artists here
hanging out with the cool dudes like now
man I [ __ ] with this dude I feel like we
are but drinking to me is like one of
those things that less conversation flow
so well yeah yeah like when I first met
you like we just click man like we're
just yeah kindred spirits you know like
you know I don't know that's that's not
thing I [ __ ] with - it's like yeah we
always I always have this [ __ ] it's like
when I [ __ ] with somebody I [ __ ] with
him really hard when I hate them I hate
them just a problem yeah like a buddy of
mine told me he was I yell bro he goes I
can tell when you hate somebody he goes
like the whole room can sense because
you're laughing at everybody [ __ ] you're
so nice and that one guy in the room you
don't like he'll say something and
you're dead faced so when David is quiet
that's why I don't even know that I do
this because I'm learning this thing
worse if you don't like somebody or you
don't like something just keep your
mouth shut but it's just all in my face
like I'm your sight damn I don't like
this guy but I don't want to I don't
want to be disrespectful but it's
already there you know yeah I see you
and I don't speak that means I'll [ __ ]
with ya
I don't know why thought of a cardi B
lyric yeah it's cold
yes is cold as [ __ ] but that's like 1%
of the world they're like 99% of people
usually I really like and I think that
now that you know I'm getting older I'm
being smart about the people that I'm
around if I like somebody's energy i'ma
kick it with them I'll share drinks with
them and that's the biggest thing if I
like you I'll share a drink with you if
I don't like you I ain't drinking with
you because I'm not I'm not trying to be
around you like that you know you know
that's life short man I don't know what
I'm like being around people I don't
want to be around yeah you know what I
mean and for me too like I grew up in a
Christian household dude and and I you
know I I would still call myself
Christian but the hardest thing about
being a Christian is like loving
somebody that you hate and I gotta tell
you that is the most difficult thing I
could do feel I'm just like like David
chilling the love of Christ like yeah
but I just really want to show them that
Satan side real quick you got it like I
just like it's like God is here in my
upper hand right but in the Satan's in
my back hand Jesus didn't say you
couldn't [ __ ] with them you know Jesus
what tables man yeah apparently I don't
know I wasn't there like I mean you kind
of look like put on a couple pies giving
you offerings you that's why we yeah
yeah it's just some wild [ __ ] man like
I'm I think I'm s what I love about
being getting older you know sometimes
people will they'll ask they don't like
don't you miss your youth [ __ ] that I
don't miss my youth because it's not
that the youth wasn't great but all that
[ __ ] that I had when I was younger you
know helped me develop Who I am now yeah
and I can't trade that [ __ ] you know the
bad [ __ ] all the good [ __ ] all the
fucked-up deals that I had everybody
that I've made that [ __ ] me over and the
people that build me up me is why I am
Who I am now yeah so I don't want to go
back to that dude I like that [ __ ] I
like this you know I mean yeah and it
took me a while to be able to be
comfortable with myself do I want to go
back to being a [ __ ] teenager and
[ __ ] and wondering how big my dick
should be like you know I mean [ __ ] I
don't want that [ __ ] yeah
I remember when I was a kid I used to be
watching porn of [ __ ] and then you see
this [ __ ] like 10-inch dick and I'm
like one day just like son of a [ __ ] I
think I was a little fool I get mad
upset when you know when you watch
amateur porn and you tell yourself like
these porn stars man they just pump
their dick and then you watch average
opponent and those dicks are big too and
I'm like maybe my [ __ ] just ain't tight
like but they say you keep losing weight
though every 10 pounds is like an inch
oh I'll tell you this though when I lost
that 60 pounds this is the biggest my
dick has ever been and I'm like oh my
big is not as small as I thought it was
it was just being absorbed did a girl
with small hands the first thing I do
when I go when I went on dates before I
would grab their hands
when we shake hands it feels like I'm
shaking my own hand so no any tiny
little dainty hands like whoa it's huge
use two hands so is your fiance like
she's [ __ ] three foot two and knows
and she knows four languages did you say
penis in foreign languages yeah no but
she said she's super sweet it's funny
cuz she's the exact opposite of me she's
like she's cool she's very she doesn't
really curse she yeah she's just a very
sweet sweet girl and I think I need
somebody that in my life
like somebody like that in my life
that's awesome you need that balance you
know cuz I don't have somebody like me
man it will just be the worst human
beings on earth like I feel like I could
never date another artist that would be
a point yeah cuz like I mean let's face
it we got to be selfish to succeed right
yeah dude like kind of like master art
craft or whatever yeah but if two people
are like that we're gonna see each other
oh yeah for sure
cuz do you need like mom that's what my
mom says she goes you know somebody
needs to bend their will to somebody
else you know not all the time but it
needs to be a back and forth right so if
two people are so headstrong they just
refuse to bet how do you guys ever meet
in the middle
yeah my mom's smart brother
yo she look like she's it's crazy good
this is the same woman that I grew up
with that threw a rice cooker at my
dad's head through a rice cooker my dad
said my mom so she has a crazy psycho
she's Korean
but sometimes jams bro it's crazy
through the rice cooker and still picked
the right so she threw the rice cooker
at his head and all the rice fella but
she had a bowl she caught it
she started making dinner immediately
she's so [ __ ] funny man like I had
this conversation with her and I was
telling her about my some of my friends
personal with like marital problems
right because I wanted to get her advice
because they wanted to meet up and ask
for my advice I'm like I may have some
advice for them but I'm not married so I
don't want to speak out of place yeah so
my parents have a successful marriage so
I wanted to ask them what they should do
mm-hmm and I told him about the problems
that they were having that my mom was
like they should just get divorced like
you don't you don't ever talk to people
like that and I just paused and I said I
was like you threw a loaded rice cooker
and her dad said who are you to talk if
this is what my mom says she goes mmm
you have really good memory huh holy
[ __ ] I get will you remember that she
goes you're right yeah you threw a rice
cooker at my dad's head it was a
gangster yeah she threw another one one
time is she just like still that little
porch that that tile that broke off of
the counter went through it so hard
that's her go-to weapon of choice if she
was like a Tekken characters she smokes
a cigarette look at odd wood bro Raiden
had like the rated hat is the visor you
gotta play golf afterwards right
she had a Sun Visor know what's up with
golf in Korea that's like a status thing
right I don't know man I just heard
somebody was talking about that this
chick this like good-looking chick was
like everybody wants me to go play golf
and I ain't about that but it's like a
thing wasn't a Korean girl yeah yeah
well the Korean women right in the LPGA
they're like this yeah yeah let me shall
we tell them yeah I think people are
honestly a lot about external status
right so what people view of them and I
think golfing is considered like status
especially on a western tip you know and
I mean like west like if you do golf
you're considered fancy right and so I
think like Korean people kind of adopted
that it's like if you're a businessman
you should do golf because that's how
you get business deals done and if
you're somebody who knows how to golf
it's elevated okay yeah so plastic
surgery
yeah we're dope it that should I'm
actually a woman dude you know yeah uh
yeah plastic surgeries huge increase I
know a couple of my friends that got
some [ __ ] done and because it's so cheap
out there they it's cheaper to buy your
ticket go to Korea get your surgery done
and come back than it is to get surgery
here oh that shit's weird bro like I
mean no offense to anybody in Korea but
like I was like in Kangnam or whatever
you know and you're walking around and
the girls have the bandage yeah their
nose with the screws on their face and
like walking around proud like smoking
cigarettes too yeah like I got money
fool like yeah oh they all look like
clones of each other yeah who is the
model like which model yeah I missed the
day when [ __ ] people look like humans
like that's my [ __ ] yeah you know a lot
of the stuff that they hate about
themselves is only stuff that you
personally hate about yourself other
people don't think twice about that [ __ ]
you know it's it's in a like I always
say man you we all raw let me get old
you know that's why I like I [ __ ] with
you guys so much
no matter how much you age your legacy
is still there your looks is not a
[ __ ] legacy it's not you think about
people like for example like I don't
know like not Cindy Margolis who was
wasn't a Cindy Crawford right she's
beautiful
but during the time that she was talked
about the most was in her youth she's
still beautiful now if people respected
as the amazing super price really good
her daughters her daughter's beautiful
spot you know yeah
yo bro her daughter's [ __ ] beautiful
man I didn't even have no idea all this
[ __ ] yeah so it's like and I'm not
saying that people don't respect her and
Revere her now because of what she's
accomplished mhm
but the way people were talking about
her when she was younger and what people
consider more beautiful was what was at
the height of her career yeah you know
and I think she was the girl exactly and
I feel like with your guy this is art
it's there it's your legacy it's there
you know nobody could say otherwise it's
it's [ __ ] timeless and that's what I
appreciate that's cool and you know for
me it's like I'm I'm not making art to
be oh this is me yeah honestly like I do
it because I have to do it yeah if I
didn't do it I probably be in jail
[ __ ] some you know what I mean like I
don't know yeah and you know people ask
too you know they go like how come you
don't have like art up in your house a
lot right and the reason why is because
I I think like if we're in order for me
to have art in my place I want to have a
personal connection with that person
because I want to be able to walk by
that [ __ ] and respect it hmm right so
I'm telling you man when I get a [ __ ]
one I buy a house I'm commissioned you
do art in my house man it's gonna happen
and I need a big-ass wall for these
Tommy pieces dude I've seen him do the
side of a damn football stadium not
really but like you just did the adidas
like soccer field I
yeah LA has like an official adidas
indoor soccer play yeah it's called
futsal you know yeah I know of the
facility I'd have never been there but
yeah so yeah I didn't know what futsal
was like because we're a merchant
it's like a the indoor like coming like
yeah like the street ball version of
soccer exactly like Nike has like their
facility area Mandy that has it yeah so
I think adidas only has like nine or ten
in the world and we have one pier and
like near downtown yeah we needed it and
it's cool I just painted it look at him
just fit I just I just paint it's cool
it's whatever like so that's want to see
this I'm saying like I have I love that
[ __ ] though man like you you kind of
like create I like having art that I
respect a lot right so it's like yeah I
know a lot of art where I see that oh
that's cool but I don't have a want to
buy it cuz I would have walked by it and
I wouldn't have a connection with it
yeah something that I like seeing yeah
you know what I mean so it's it's that's
what people like I even ask my friends
like they're not like really well-known
artists not great I just do for fun I
was like you know if you paint something
for me I'll put it up just because I
like you as a person and if there's a
connection to it mm-hmm
cuz art does have this weird thing where
I feel like it's and I think this is why
I don't know how people feel about
Street I like street art because it's
just art for what art is it's not some
rich holy xx person saying like this is
worth a million dollars so I'm telling
you is worth a million dollars like I
could look at and say that's [ __ ]
dope yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] the hype yeah yeah I
would never want to buy something
because of the hype yeah you know look
at me I'm [ __ ] I went into a I went
into the [ __ ] Road yeah at the Broad
Museum yeah there was a [ __ ] painting
worth like [ __ ] like three million
dollars and it was the I'm sorry not a
painting it was chalk art and the guy
just drew a line of dicks I did that in
the fourth grade
massive attack abroad
you could yes there was somebody else
who put up a wall and it was just like
two plus two equals four and they were
scratching all this like random
mathematic equations
I'm like bro every Asian little kid
should be on in here then are you
[ __ ] kidding me
and it wasn't worth like ten million
dollars I will [ __ ] stab you in the
eye and that was just a bunch of rich
people that got together and said yo
that's some next-level [ __ ] and then
they they made it ten million dollars
yeah imma leave I mean I could talk a
lot of [ __ ] about the art world like I
don't want to but it's literally
controlled by the top tier people yeah
like the top I don't know there's a
couple right yeah three or four and
auction houses and they kind of set the
thing yeah and everybody else we're just
kind of like fighting for scraps or
whatever yeah that's why I like murals
yeah like I mean I'm not a [ __ ] I'll do
stuff too but like I've been just doing
murals and yeah it's just a little too
like I don't know what would you call it
like snobby you know what like paying up
millions or I'm not gonna kiss an ass
yeah I mean like you are not gonna yeah
I would I would die in Hollywood with
you bro yeah honestly yeah does not kiss
one I've never seen a kiss I want ads
the way I'm talking to you guys is the
way I talk to like a CEO and that's how
it should feel like my friends to like
church pastor you know I like the
accessibility of street art maybe that's
what I like so much about it right
anybody can look at it and appreciate it
mm-hmm you don't have to be an art major
to say that's dope you don't have to be
like oh did you know that this empty
that this white canvas is supposed to
represent the emptiness of the spirits
of people in LA get the [ __ ] out of my
face with that [ __ ] dude and like
Instagram has or this whole social
platform has created the accessibility
for artists yeah and like street art
realm or whatever our realm yeah you see
them you follow them you can buy their
ship by hitting them up basically on a
text message yeah which like which I
think would probably mean a lot more to
a collector or or a fan way more than
just that kind of idea like someone
telling you this is what it's about and
then you spend your whole check on some
I don't know [ __ ] the most is one when I
went to the broad I actually recorded my
something you're supposed to record
yourself and I'm just like clowning on
people I saw this girl stand in front of
that dick mural right and she just was
sitting even with the arm cross with her
hand on her chin like she goes yes yes
yes okay what yes what what's she trying
to suck them DS and then her boyfriend
is like indulging her or whatever the
date that she's odd he goes yeah I could
see yeah it meant like this is [ __ ]
some next-level [ __ ] like I wanted a
Tonya Harding [ __ ] [ __ ] lead
tighten me captain and I just like
you're literally feeding into your own
[ __ ] man it's okay for you to say I
don't know what the [ __ ] I'm looking at
it's okay yeah that speaks to the power
[ __ ] man say the same thing I'm like
that all museums and art galleries like
like 75% of it is like a guy trying to
get laid right yeah you know what - can
you hear me Tommy broke the mic don't
[Laughter]
you guys a good one yeah [ __ ] if I
yeah but we're speaking of art let's
take another shot oh [ __ ]
by the way David um you told me you have
a flight later today and you can take it
easy but we finish this bottle yeah we
bought that bottle on the way over here
yeah yeah yep Cheers oh we kill the
bottle yeah dupit son of a [ __ ] it was
like I I got a flight to catch and I got
another podcast so I can't drink that
much but we did it
I hope the next podcast is with like Jim
Carrey or something so yeah pull it
together to do some now a lot but it's
it's gonna be a serious podcast as you
know the guess is on his um a girl who
was a fan in advance still huh and she
owns like her own personal bakery
company but she goes to a lot of like
personal turmoil it was suicide and she
was gonna kill herself and the chef
scene DM me and I don't know what it's
like to deal with suicide I have never
had suicidal thoughts up now I'm good so
you're not a painter like I I don't know
I don't know what it was about my
upbringing but I never thought about
killing myself like it was just never
one of those thoughts so I can't really
relate to it but a lot of kids asked
like how do I deal with these thoughts
where I feel like worthless I never felt
a quote worthless to that extent so I
want her to talk about her experiences I
had to try to talk her out of it but uh
I don't I don't know how was she she had
suicidal thoughts and she uh she tried
actually she's actually tried okay
it was tragic - and it didn't work Oh
should you know and in my mind a hurt
thing was you know she went through a
lot and so she's looking at her hers and
her cup half empty all the time but how
I saw it from an outside perspective
mm-hmm if you have people who are
positive in your life and they can talk
to you I'm just like yo like you went
through all this personal [ __ ] but you
somehow ended up being your own personal
business owner hopping off yeah that's
amazing to me like you thought it is the
odds but I think for in her case she was
focusing so much on the negative she
couldn't move past it mm-hmm and it's
hard sometimes like I I completely get
it it's [ __ ] hard yeah he's an artist
bro
she is I've had that I've had those
thoughts you know multiple times
growing up like I could I could just
drive off this bridge right now and like
no one were really even [ __ ] know you
know I'm saying but it's about that push
through and they're like I don't know
what's gonna happen but there's more
later I don't think it's it's I don't
even know if I could explain it but like
but look at slots come to everybody yeah
I see it in two ways like some people
are like did they see the the glass is
half empty yeah and I don't see hope in
it right so it's like what the [ __ ] are
you gonna do you know and it's amazing -
yeah and what I say - it's like those
moments where you feel so insignificant
in this whole world and imagine would
have happened if both of you never
existed I would have never met you or
you and I met you in an instant I'm
[ __ ] bi with you like that right and
then the moment that I vie with you it's
like now you've affected my whole day
for the rest of the day you know like
it's like oh we're having a great time
you know people wouldn't enable to see
your art your art so dope that people
bite off that [ __ ] you know they would
have never had careers and I also think
like is my beginning a little too Jeep
but be an artist we think a lot yeah
yeah yeah - you know you - yeah you know
you're in comedy and like it's creative
in general we kind of like our job is to
analyze things in life and kind of
regurgitate it in our version yeah and
it's kind of like an old philosopher
it's like when we know the truths of
things it's very depressing we don't
know the answer you know I mean so like
that's that's why I think there's a
stigma of artists being like sad and
depressed it's because of that like they
see they analyze life and they see the
truths of life that's what is blessed
man
yeah like the matrix right like the the
background matrix you once you knew the
truth and we get that steak and [ __ ] you
know yeah yeah yeah I I think I start to
realize that more when I see people who
just don't give a [ __ ] about anything
and they live in ignorance they're
always happy yeah once and once in a
while I kind of envy that
so I go to my nine-to-five job come home
yes like I eat dinner with my wife or
whatever watch a little bit of something
TV and go to sleep you know what I say
that I'm pandering to them yeah but I'm
not yeah your reality is what you make
out of it right yeah so I say like in
the other although you're saying like
the 9:00 to 5:00 is better you're just
like you know being your pattern no I'm
not
what I'm saying is is that what you live
in fulfills you to the max yeah with the
more knowledge you gain and the more you
think outside of your head it's hard to
fill that hole
it's fun it's [ __ ] hard because the
moment you feel satisfaction in
something it disappears and then you got
to do something else with it yeah and
that's the whole I think that's the most
one one of the most difficult things
about being somebody who loves art it's
that pursuit of being constantly
satisfied with everything that you do
you're just growing all the time and you
never know if you're gonna actually grow
into what you want to be by the time you
die never satisfied I don't know how you
are with you with your stuff but never
every time I release up there like I
look at that Mike that's like it's a
part yeah
you know but yeah but then I feel like
I'm doing something right right
you are yeah because like if I kept
making the same thing over and over
again yeah maybe I probably way more
richer but and one of the things that
I've learned especially then maybe not
so much in your guys remain mine too
it's like you have to understand that
people get entertainment from what I do
I I have to understand it and they're
still taking something away so what is
the root core of why I do it I do it for
myself and I want to make people happy
so even if you don't like it all the way
somebody is walking away and learning
something from what you do so you're
still getting your job done it's this
you don't have to look for me I don't
have to love it all the way mm-hmm but
if I if I don't do something simply
because it's not perfect I'm never gonna
grow yeah never you gotta you gotta let
go of perfection yes there's a there's
no such thing
see ya he's 300 bro do as he's speaking
his [ __ ] Chinese whiskers are growing
you see a staff in his head
[ __ ] to 100 mojo emoji we need
and a scroll clubs out though someone is
watching this right now hanging on every
word because it's helping them that much
yeah listen I'm not here to preach or
[ __ ] whatever man I'm just here
talking about myself yeah you know any
of my experience like what I say might
not work for you
whatever you know I mean but this is my
experience you know like and I don't
know man I've been making more art my
whole life and I'm [ __ ] here with mr.
Polansky
no good [ __ ] man and but really like
putting the [ __ ] in my life right now
it's because I think there was a couple
years of my life where I made this film
and I thought after that I didn't know
what to do it was because I wasn't
grateful for my [ __ ] it's like you know
I could be doing any I could be working
an office job right now just trying to
get by but I'm getting by with the art
that I'm making which is a lot of people
want this life they want your life and
you are an artist by the way just like
we are for real cuz nobody lives like
this it's most is 99% cheapo and I don't
mean that in a negative term I just mean
most people are in that line of getting
a nine-to-five and have them getting my
kids and [ __ ] but we are on this other
we're going our own paths off on the
side and [ __ ] and like no one
understands it and that's fine yeah but
also they thrive on it yeah we they need
us to do this so they don't have to yeah
yeah yeah yeah I don't I don't even know
what the [ __ ] I'm saying yeah you know
anything and it works the other way
around too like I need to be around to
appreciate what I do need a foundation
man yeah so it's it's all like
reciprocal energy right psych I get to
do what I do because of you that's why
when I say thank you to two fans and
people who appreciate me I mean that
from the deepest part of my [ __ ] soul
I don't get to do what I do with without
you yeah I say I create for myself but I
still present it to you that I don't
want you to affect my art where I don't
get to do what I want to do but I still
want to present it to you it's still a
piece of me and so you know when I when
I appreciate people I really do [ __ ]
appreciate them man cuz if there wasn't
an audience to see our
where would our stuff be we would still
create but I'm not gonna lie it feels
good when somebody appreciates my [ __ ]
totally the fish you know Oh painter you
know yeah and I said I get once in a
while like little fan mails and odmg
like yeah you know I mean like I'm like
wait you like my stuff okay cool yeah
you know and like I know it's not like
as big of an outreach it as you have but
it's like I mean it's it's it kind of
like makes me want to keep doing this
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah when I get like
messages and they go you know when I was
younger I wasn't a confident human being
and just watching you be who you are it
made me a confident person those little
moments make me work harder yeah like to
like someone that's watching this right
now doesn't realize that we're just like
some smokes
yeah the trash yeah literally yeah we're
just like living art trying to live our
pet slow looking trying to grab the
empty but like they can do all this yeah
you just have to put the time into it
yeah and like time is energy so like
that you just have to put the energy
into it that's it yeah you know like
anybody with a tiny idea it can be this
huge thing that changes the world but
it's what you put into that ship yeah Oh
like that's nothing you know I mean
that's it period but I'm just saying
yeah but that's a that's some
interesting stuff to like I always say a
lot of people want what somebody else
has but the but they're not willing to
put the reps in mm-hmm you know it's
preps and let me tell you David like as
I guess amazing right yes bro you look
like a racist Asian
what as an Asian person in Asian America
American I'm American right as an Asian
person like like like people seeing
people like you it makes me like I feel
good you know like because me I'm a
painter I'm an artist like my world is
very niche yeah like people that are
into art will like it and then people
that are not whatever you know but like
you you have a broader are the audience
and like people like you and like all
our other homies that are in Hollywood
and like and the mass media and stuff
like that I [ __ ] love it man like you
guys have a stepping stone to like our
whoever the next the Asian denzel's
gonna be really yeah I'm waiting for
that moment where we could just really
inspire the next like I don't have to be
that person but if I can get that next
person there I'm good man I could die
happy yeah like that's okay man like
[ __ ] glory to myself man
like who cares about that [ __ ] I even
said before like I could be okay
disappearing off the face of the earth
as long as like financially I'm stable
and I can do what I want you know no one
wants to be famous man but I want to get
that check exactly
like you know people will always like
I've always said this too it's just you
know if I if I walked outside this door
and a duffel bag full of ten million
dollars and they go what would you do
different nothing I stick my cheek and
go to an island yeah you know I mean
maybe I'll leave her now I'm getting I
would be doing my same [ __ ] still doing
the podcast still creating the same
thing yeah but I would just have not had
the financial worry anymore cuz at the
end of it the the core thing is I still
enjoy what I'm doing and I have to enjoy
what I'm doing cuz we just said it in
this podcast life is short I got one
life that's it and I don't know what's
gonna happen I might get cancer I might
get hit by a [ __ ] car any of that
[ __ ] might might happen I'm not I'm not
immortal so while I am here I have to
enjoy what I'm doing and on top of that
I have to respect what I'm doing - [ __ ]
money I could do whatever I want for
money man I could go start I could have
done one the whole YouTube prank [ __ ]
happen I could have done pranks I could
have [ __ ] dropped the Mentos in a
coke bottle shot it up my mouth and got
a million views
but what kind of legacy does that leave
me behind and will I be able to look at
that and say you know what dude I I did
something great no I wouldn't be able to
say that watch somebody come up to me
and be like yo you're the Mentos guy
I'll [ __ ] shoot my pressure I know for
this if you look on the gift the gift
keyboard there's like this [ __ ] right
there was tossing dollar bills sometimes
people come up to me like a gift
keyboard guy I'm like [ __ ] you I sold my
old film and they're like give keep yo
gifts for the future man if you don't
have a gift you're [ __ ]
you [ __ ] I got a gift I like to call
it jiff T Oh mmm III do have a is it a
Filth what'd he call it a filter jiffy
brought jiffy on things to Dell adesso
holler that's also the same fool that
got his arts night for Taco Bell
he's the he's the grime master who's
made a bunch of different jiffy's for
all of us my balloon Skeet Tommy Lim
bloody gums pizza boys everybody
included man that's amazing David you
have a jiffy uh-uh I don't [ __ ] know
random like [ __ ] like gifs of me but
I just didn't sketches and I'm like no
more like I did this like one pick-up
line on this sketch where this girl came
up and I told her feel my shirt and she
was like I like you know what that's
made of she's like well that's boyfriend
material I know you as the homie like
what are you most known for like in
general like when people come up to you
I mean definitely for my youtube stuff
like the film stuff is not really there
yet
[ __ ] was wait wait oh by the way did
goop he was just telling me about goop
did you produce that he produced it and
then I kind of developed the character
in the background for it so I kind of
like
we're interpreting ideas and stuff you
know watch GU watch goo thanks man
I'll be watching to whom we're here but
it was amazing yeah yeah and you know
for me too like because I don't think I
ever wanted to be a film writer an actor
or a producer mm-hmm like I'm okay with
leaving that film and not making another
one
oh I'll still right now make some other
[ __ ] like I'm writing stuff right now
but it was such a personal thing for me
it felt great you know like I got the I
got the showa side of myself that people
don't normally see you know and then on
top of that I got to show a character
that people don't expect out of an Asian
guy you know the kid that wanted to be
an R&B singer that grew up in the hood
they always think of us as accountants
and I'm okay with that too you know some
Asian stereotypes aren't that bad like
oh look at you you're gonna be a doctor
okay oh but I'm a savior your dad from
dying from cancer okay whatever Oh looks
like I bet you have a good credit score
yeah all right math but you know I'm
glad I'm glad like just on the right now
level I'm glad that you got that out
merely because Holly was gonna pick up
on that and then pull you know like ten
different like directions oh and that's
great because them checks are gonna
[ __ ] flow and you can still work that
subliminal that's what I'm really trying
to do man I'm trying to like speak my
[ __ ] without having some that's the hard
part about going to auditions and kind
of doing that Hollywood game is that you
it's a business model so you're trying
to work within it mm but that's hard for
me man because I've always just did
stuff that [ __ ] with me first
yeah then all the all the other [ __ ] is
just a cherry on top
yeah yeah how the [ __ ] is that [ __ ]
right now at like almost 20/20 as a
Asian like writer actor comedian like
what was the like I mean it's weird
because you know people yeah they want
Asian content but they want their type
of Asian content mm-hmm
they don't know about the kid that grew
up in Sacramento or around a
predominantly black neighborhood there's
no like a liquor store owner like the
type of [ __ ] they want kung fu [ __ ] they
want kung fu [ __ ] yeah they want that
Chinese immigrant story stuff I don't
have that regular Asian
story I grew up in South Sacramento
California I grew up on a predominantly
black neighborhood my parents own a
black beauty supply store I was I wanted
to be an RnB [ __ ] singer certain
point I want to be a rapper I said this
guy's a good singer by the way anywhere
and you know I went into comedy right
that's my story yeah sometimes like yo
can you give me a story about like your
parents coming on a boat and then you
know you you know you're working I don't
have that story my parents came on a
plane [ __ ] you don't mean fresh
out the PRU yeah like that's that's my
[ __ ] you know so I can't you know I
understand it's the business model so
they want to hear stories that people
want to hear America is not ready for
that [ __ ] they're not ready for the kid
that grew up in an all-black
neighborhood his best friend's black you
know I mean that you know I grew up
saying the n-word all the time but you
don't say it as much anymore I try not
to at all mm-hmm but you know obviously
all of us did I mean all of us did long
ago real yeah you know I mean because
you know it was encouraged out of us you
know up on hip hop to like exactly right
so they don't want it they don't know
these stories right mm-hmm and I I got
to stick with that story because that's
a story I want to tell that's what [ __ ]
was it was a story that we wanted to
tell ya the Justin want to tell the
story that I wanted to tell and and
there was a niche group of people that
resonated with it they're like you know
that was me growing up yeah you know you
speak for me and that's what I want I
don't need to speak for everybody I got
to be for myself first yeah I grew up in
LA like during the [ __ ] riots yes
probably junior high school or something
but like a [ __ ] resonated you know
honey [ __ ] dude yeah yeah have you had a
lot of people that have come up to say
that that that's really something that
spoke to me yeah and I should because
that's like a heavy message right oh man
when people say they should do it it
makes me feel good man cuz I'm like damn
I did my job
like do you feel like that was kind of
like more more of your art piece yeah
yeah it was an art piece man yeah and
that's something that I could leave up
and be [ __ ] proud of till the day that
I die yeah I could keep that off like
unlike in my heart and I mean like deal
I'm proud of that [ __ ] for sure you know
blood sweat and tears made no money off
that [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ]
it's something that I'm proud of [ __ ]
yeah you know people are like you know
you know what people mentioned it seems
like so long ago like I don't really
talk about it much because now I'm on to
the next thing
sure but I'm still proud of it you know
like it's not who I am
but it's my art piece an old wide
distribution like yeah it's a joke
because it's so accessible oh yeah yeah
I like it even with the food stuff that
I have right and I like accessibility
why do I like bougie food right I think
it tastes great I want people see my
bucket you know why because my outline
happens you know I don't want people to
my friends Moutai all the time you know
me so it's great for kicking yeah it's
not great for other people yeah I have
the movement yeah the ability to kick
somebody in the neck yeah like the light
of your pants are the easier it is for
you to kick somebody the more you can
see someone's balls the more accessible
the face kick is if you meet somebody
and you can see their ball sack they do
[Laughter]
I'm dying
yeah oh [ __ ] hey you know what though
man we're an hour and thirty minutes in
usually this podcast like 45 minutes no
really and it promotes some [ __ ] oh
that's what we're gonna do before we end
I want you guys to put them all all your
[ __ ] okay laughs okay that's gonna get
me way drunk but all right I'll taste it
wait is it so this is actually really
good I came out with a drink in Japan
it's called Kiva which means fangs and
things in Japanese its energy drinking
vodka oh yeah it's like a for luckless
bro this is a for local crazy [ __ ] for
look
but it actually tastes pretty good and
it's probably equivalent to like I pee
or something okay come bear yeah Cheers
I'm bad yeah come bear okay that's
[ __ ] addictive that's that's all bad
for me I'll get smashed
Red Bull yes so I'm currently working on
a installation oh [ __ ]
the house litter his [ __ ] music
[Laughter]
David so [ __ ] you give up this Hollywood
[ __ ] he's like yeah smoke a
cigarette can we take the microphones
with us to the balcony
yeah are you still trying to hide that
[ __ ] from your mom I just get we can go
for another hour is there seriously
someone waiting outside though they're
at 3:00 so she's 10 minutes early that's
not good okay yes all right what am i
doing
I'm working on a mural installation
right now for a big event called sneaker
topia yeah it's a it's gonna be a
sneaker museum starting in LA at Culver
City okay and I got Belinsky to add some
balloons to my installation but um just
like the history of sneakers and like
just show off like the sneaker culture
and stuff like that I'm working out
there right now and got some other stuff
coming up but up I want to show the the
print I gave you go Bruce Lee print oh
yes yes yes let me let me hold on a
second man I mean this is cute no this
background right here but I think you
need a little bit more it is a nice like
background though I was commenting on
that when we first got here actually
that that's a cool like nothing graphic
it's very emoji you know new yeah very
millennial
it's so yeah so a few months back I had
a solo exhibition called odd man out and
it was about like us like us in general
like not feeling feeling uh in tune with
who who we are in the society you know
and then I I've never done ever done
like the Asian perspective thing you
know yeah like I did a giant painting of
Bruce Lee and I called a Chino died yeah
you know so like I grew up hating Bruce
Lee Oh like people kept calling me clean
it was like a race it was like yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah operations they keep
calling me like Bruce Lee Jackie Chan
like you know whatever and then um like
I hated Bruce Lee and then when I got
older I realized like how important he
was for just Asians in general right
like as a as an actor as yeah a symbol
right so like I painted a giant Bruce
Lee painting and I didn't want to
monetize off a bristly like to Shannon
and Lee and whoever else like yeah I was
trying to make money off of it you know
I mean like I just like wanted to show
like how he represented us as a culture
so um you know I did a giant painting
and I made some t-shirts and I'm a
gifting David a Hager and beginning is
stuff you know yeah do you have any
connections to like like Shannon Lee or
anybody no I have no connections to that
yeah because I have a 10-foot Bruce Lee
painting I'm not trying to sell I would
love to donate it to yeah just some
Asian thing somewhere you know me like
so yeah yeah man I'm telling you like
it's weird because people like I respect
Bruce Lee but Bruce Lee wasn't a part of
my life because of how I grew up
yeah I mean like I grew up in a
predominantly black neighborhood you
know so Bruce Lee wasn't somebody I
needed to look up to I I knew who Bruce
Lee was I loved the kung fu [ __ ] but I
feel like a lot a lot of kids growing up
they're like yo Bruce Lee was my idol
Bruce Lee was never mile Bruce Lee was
somebody that I knew it he was dope I
[ __ ] with like Sylvester Stallone John
Claude Van Damme yeah you know which is
odd you know what I mean and people I
think sometimes people feel weird about
that like why don't you look up to Bruce
Lee or I looked at the Jackie Chan
because it was just I didn't I didn't
feel like I was I had a push that I was
Asian I was I'm just an Asian guy yeah
you know I mean so I I wore look I wore
my Korea flag on my back
% yeah I just never shoved it in
people's faces I'm just Korean that's
why it's like the America [ __ ] - yeah
jean-claude van damme yeah Jackie Chan I
mean I watched all that - I met back up
here yeah yeah yeah you know maybe like
water my friend
yeah he's like seventies yeah yeah yeah
yeah but it's but still it resonate
resonated as a racial slur to us I mean
you know what's [ __ ] funny - man yes
that whole Bruce Lee concept - it's like
you know people hate hate me when I say
the [ __ ] but I think Bruce Lee was high
all the time his [ __ ] dude we yo
you want to talk about it
you he's in an interview a serious
interview and they go like how's your
day you when you put water into the
copper water to a tea pot becomes the
people be like water my friend I'm like
300 like any human being that's talking
to me like that I'm like [ __ ]
what are you on yeah I know edibles for
sure right yeah yeah respect yeah I come
all and they trying to blame it on the
weed when he died yeah what nah wait
what hold on no we don't kill yeah we
don't kill no for real yeah yeah I think
there's a point where they try to blame
whatever marijuana stuff he was taken as
the the reason why he passed so what was
the reason why Bruce Lee actually when I
know his son got shot on a movie set
it didn't happen with him overdose
overdose yeah but people you know they
have like their own well Hollywood I'll
[ __ ] you up with that bro yo man [ __ ]
Heath Ledger overdosed hundred-person a
bunch of other people I also feel like
you overexerted his body like yeah max
even though he's like the pinnacle of
what a human can be yeah you can still
go to the point of like yes yeah for
sure 100% yeah well before we sign out
for me uh shot your [ __ ] out homey at
balloon ski ballon ski that's all
Instagram everything right everything
paluska calm yeah man support we really
here for Tommy Lim
now we here for everybody man I'm going
to [ __ ] with anybody that's just my
friends I don't give a [ __ ]
alright job well you could catch this on
Spotify stitcher Eddie you know [ __ ]
iTunes podcast give us that five star
leave comments below if you're watching
this on YouTube man like I said this
podcast about anybody and everybody that
I [ __ ] with it doesn't have to be like
the celebrity that you know about like
everybody has great stories man and I
and I really appreciate you guys coming
on man
it's probably one of my favorite podcast
I've ever day man thanks for having us
follow me on instagram at Tommy T Oh mmm
III two M's two ice that's it how do you
spell balloon ski two L's two O's there
you go but lows me baby and if you want
to go old school my website is ugly
fresh com that's right you'll see a
bunch of his old porn tapes
[Laughter]